الاشاعات والمعلومات المضلله التي يتم
تداولها على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي فضلا
عن تنامي خطاب الكراهيه في الاردن يرهق
اجهزه الدوله
[موسيقى]
فمنصات التواصل الاجتماعي اصبحت بيئه خصبه
للاشاعات خاصه في اوقات الازمات والطوارئ
حيث فاقع عدد هذه الاشاعات خلال جائحه
كورونا ال 500 اشاعه
[موسيقى]
ما دفع الحكومه الى اطلاق مواقع الكترونيه
ومراست خاصه لتقصي حجم الظاهره وتبعتها
على المجتمع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
جرائم القطع والذم والتحقير تحتل المرتبه
الاولى في الشكاوى والدعم المقدمه الى
الاجهزه المتخصصه في الاردن وهي تمثل ما
يقارب ثلثي الجرائم المرتكبه عبر وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي ومن بين المبادرات
اللافته التي اطلقت في هذا السياق مركز
لرصد ومتابعه خطاب الكراهيه والمعلومات
المضلله والاشاعات تحديدا عبر وسائل
التواصل
ويرى متخصصون ان نشره تربيه الاعلاميه
والمعلوماتيه ودمج مفاهيمها في المناهج
التعليميه بالمدارس والجامعات كفلان
بمحاربه الاشاعات والمعلومات المضلله كما
ان اتاحه المعلومات العامه للمواطنين من
خلال ضمان حق الحصول عليها فضلا عن تعزيز
دور الصحافه الجيده والاخلاقيه قد تاتي
بثمار ايجابيه